you should have seen us three hours he
does like in a robe with puffy slippers
eating pizza he had no pants on it was
really is quite a sight and her condo is
all windows and I'm like closing the
blinds so he's like everybody can see us
walking around I'm like now they can
waving at the building across the street
and some Calvin Klein's that's me Ruby
on snapchat soon I'm sure thank you I
have been handling everything I'm just
so exhausted flowers well no because I
was like is there anything you really
want to do and he's like walk down the
aisle to the Batman theme song and I'm
like and we're done I'll handle it from
here a nice orchestrated version not
like some cheesy one yeah
realize
Lanner we have a planner as soon as I
realized I wasn't have to move back here
to shoot then I was like let a planner
handle it I'm not gonna be there so it's
much easier now know designated survivor
no no absolutely not I couldn't believe
it I feel like somehow I snuck a seat at
the big kids table
so I'm just like waiting for them to be
like oh we're just kidding you can go
back to ABC Family it's like watching
the first night that I met keeper
Sutherland Italia had him in a headlock
so they became fast friends a good
headlock he was to give each at the
wedding and I was like I just met you
like two days ago
so he's not even invited maybe yeah I
don't know we'll see we'll see how
shooting goes I know he walks in and
he's like why do you have Jack Bauer in
a headlock and I was like oh it's this
at school is fine I think everybody we
never we never go out so it's like I
don't get to do the night of it yeah
we don't lazy yeah we're old we're like
it happened in the morning 90 years old
on the inside